[Music]
we don't do who he'd love he wouldn't
exist I'm good it's like nothing really
matters to him right now
including me you gotta think real hard
about this do you have people that need
you no I'm taking the fight
Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who
infamously kill Apollo tree appeared
today to issue a challenge to Adonis
Creed don't do this
ain't got a choice that's the same thing
your father said you died right here to
my head
that kid was raised in Haiti dangerous
he broke things to me that I never been
fixed ain't worth it
is not just us anymore of date I want to
rewrite history if you will to fight
this man that's your business
but don't pretend this is about your
father this here is all about my kids
it was right without
[Music]
the tribulation
this won't be the end of me
are you
they can't because we a team
[Music]
now you notified before
Brown left of brown you learn more about
yourself when I stepped in Henry it
wasn't all about me
I do it again what do you have to prove
it's not about that
you wouldn't be any good to anybody if
you didn't do what you love you wouldn't
be able to breathe right well I wouldn't
be any good to anybody if I don't handle
this the right way
but I need you
I'll be too
you better don't think I could be is
that what you're trying to say no that's
not what I'm saying I'm say I'm not
gonna be here forever then what's that
supposed to mean it means you got to do
some smart thinking are you want to talk
about smart decisions Rock you and this
house all alone who've been taking care
you mean I've been here for you well she
got
listen
I'm taking this fight with or without
you
Bianca Taylor you're the only person
I want to share my moments we got this I
was really excited about building on
these characters that we were so
familiar with and in relationship with
Bianca and having that evolve which is
really really important to Adonis and
his evolution as a boxer but if there
was the central themes of this film I
think it would be family there's so much
emotional stuff going on on both sides
Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who
infamously kill Apollo Creed appeared
today to issue a challenge to Adonis
Creed Ivan Drago he's sitting on this
pain and anger towards the world because
33 years ago he lost the fight to Rocky
Balboa because of you I lose everything
so draaga wants to win at all costs and
he has to use his son to get there the
only thing that Victor wanted was to
actually get the respect and love of his
father
I think a darkness has always felt like
he had something to prove and gotta take
the fight he's got nothing to lose
when plater ain't got nothing to lose
he's dangerous
she don't think I could beat rocky
realizes it all he has is Adonis and
he's afraid that history is gonna repeat
itself spouses of boxers as a team the
concept of we versus I so when he goes
to fight she's in the ring with him
family element is important to Adonis
and Bianca is on board Rocky's on war
his mom is on board everybody's fighting
drug
he's just a man be more man than him in
this movie and we want to explore the
dinosaur being humble and then being
reborn and become a man he really wants
to be Adonis has to figure out about
what you're fighting for is something
bigger than just yourself breathe worse
Drago this is the fight the whole world
wants to see Adonis feels like you
should avenge his father but Rocky's
afraid that history is gonna repeat
itself he's dangerous
I'm dangerous he has a daughter now he
has to come back to cuz he's not going
to repeat his father's mistakes you can
always relate to 100 dog story was
fighting for something who has passion
it's very emotional and the action is
there the fights are there I think we
found the right combination
some big guys sitting over there waiting
for you he said y'all know who he is
you ukrainian boxer victor drago appear
today in philadelphia
bringing back Ivan Drago and his son
Victor in that history that animosity it
just made it more intense
this is Creed versed Drago this is the
fight the whole world wants to see
nonetheless he's afraid of history
repeat itself
Rocky's past has caught up to him
because the darkest moment in Rocky's
life is when Apollo Creed's substituted
for him it's a fight Drago and he died
and so now the donnas Creed feels like
you should avenge his father ain't got a
choice that's the same thing your father
said and he died right here in my head
Ivan Drago is the iconic character for
destroying one of our other iconic aired
as Apollo Creed so it was really cool to
revive him in a way that felt fresh and
new because of you I lose everything
Yvonne was a Olympic champion he was a
hero of the soviet union but 33 years
ago he lost a fight with the true Rocky
Balboa
so now he's trying to turn his life
around
using his son as the vehicle for him to
come back onto the world stage
perhaps Oh No
because of the history it's easy to make
this match up so this is his big chance
and it's not about treats about him and
his father I will break you to money you
know the stakes it's a loaded situation
these dudes killed my pops I can't let
that slide the ciock laid out in the new
generation with a news Drago get a new
create Billy's fantastic this is our
chance to be right
what they don't know is the [ __ ] the
drama
the guns the city the father the baby's
mama
the things we use the stuff
somebody stop somebody coming
with the dock the light my heart
the right is done
I was afraid I couldn't live up to the
expectation you don't think you got your
validation for me this is the first time
having a sequel to anything so I was
really excited about building on the
characters you have people they need you
know the second one we learn to make
things a little bigger bring him back
Ivan Drago and his son Victor and that
history that animosity with Creed and
rocky it just made it that much more
intense this guy is dangerous I got a
choice nice to soother your father said
right here in my face you can always
relate 200 dog story to the person who's
fighting for something who has passion
it was easy want to be a part of
something that was human if you want to
fight this man that's your business
but don't pretend this is about your
father Ryan Coogler suggested Stephen
and I was excited to work with Stephen I
was really looking forward to building
something with him Ellicott we
understood it he just wanted to go the
distance what a talented director he is
I could tell he was gonna be great for
this picture it's not just us anymore t
that's exactly why I can't lose Stephen
is very much his own voice and wants to
come in and tell his own story inside of
this I wanna be right history that's one
of the challenges when you're getting
passed the torch by two legendary
filmmakers in sylvester stallone and
ryan coogler have been very helpful at
the saying hey this
this world is like how do we stay true
that Wow putting your own stamp on the
sea I played out in the new generation
with the new guy it was fantastic
I may not seem like it now but this is
more than just fight this team has been
a blast he's a really strong leader and
you want to follow him Cree were
stronger this is the fight the whole
world wants to see bring him back Ivan
Drago and his son Victor made it more
intense you're much smaller than before
it's a loaded situation
these dudes killed my pops Ivan Drago
has been established but we haven't seen
him in years
Yvan was a little bit champion he was a
hero of the soviet union but 33 years
ago he lost a fight to Rocky Balboa
because of you a loser the dictator
Franco represents revenge so now he's
blaming his entire self destruction on
rocky but now he's trying to come back
onto the world stage and he has to use
his son to get there your parade no no
Tina per unit so we're coming to America
to put on this fight against darkness
and confront rocky to let him know that
you do this to me not I'm gonna do this
to you and your boy my son will break
your ward
[Music]
never
Bianca she's someone that really has her
own agency and you see that reflected in
her music this phone people wanted to
have their own careers and passions but
learning how to have love together as
well so we really follow their journey
what's the next step in a relationship
Bianca supports her man through and
through it I think but she's gets the
look at Drago she's like oh boy
be that person to stop you I don't want
to end up alone
Bianca understands why he feels like he
has to take the fight Tommy don't but I
need you but she's incredibly conflicted
because it's a huge risk
it's not just us anymore tea
and this one it really is like she's in
the ring with him we got this yummy in
the ring you got rules I'd say you got
nothing
life history with all these cheap shots
people like me living past you got
people that you need you you know you
got everything to loose this guy he's
got nothing to loose I got a choice
that's the same thing your father said
and he died right here in my hands this
to me this guy is dangerous
but you don't think I could beat I was
afraid I couldn't live up to these
expectations
you don't think you got your validation
I got
I want to rewrite history don't pretend
this is about your father
[Music]
they may not seem like it now but this
is more than just fight
is that my DNA
[Music]